si tenemos una masa m que se está
moviendo con cierta velocidad ve podemos
ver la magnitud de la velocidad sabemos
que este objeto tiene momento momento
transnacional y este momento que
expresamos con la letra ro
se define como la masa multiplicada por
la velocidad esa es sólo una revisión
tenemos otros videos en donde hablamos
con más detalle acerca de estos
conceptos una forma intuitiva de pensar
el momento transnacional es imaginarnos
qué tan difícil no sería detener esta
masa que trae esta velocidad comúnmente
decimos que algo trae cierto momento y
mientras más momento traiga más difícil
será detenerlo este es el concepto que
surgió históricamente en el contexto de
la mecánica newtoniana veamos esto
matemáticamente esto significa que el
producto entre la magnitud de la fuerza
y la duración el tiempo de aplicación de
esta que llamamos impulso
va a ser igual al cambio en el momento
esto como ya mencionamos es solo una
revisión de los conceptos que ya hemos
visto esto va a ser igual al cambio en
el momento si no tenemos ningún impulso
ninguna fuerza neta que esté actuando en
el objeto su momento va a ser constante
lo vimos en la conservación del momento
y usamos esta idea en diversas
aplicaciones interesantes de la física
una de ellas era usando bolas de billar
ahora tratemos de usar una idea similar
pero ahora en el mundo de la rotación
imaginemos que tenemos esta masa y para
facilitarnos los cálculos imaginemos que
este es un punto de masa esta masa va a
estar conectada a un clavo mediante un
cable sin masa y esto de aquí va a ser
su centro de rotación así que pueden
imaginarse que si alguien aplica un
torque aquí a esta masa ésta comenzará a
rotar en un círculo e imaginen que esta
masa se encuentra sobre la pantalla o
sobre una superficie que no tienen nada
de fricción y tampoco hay resistencia al
aire
esta es una masa puntual por lo que si
aplicamos torque aquí comenzará a rotar
y habíamos comentado que el momento va
con esta idea de qué tan difícil sería
detener el movimiento de esta masa
evitar que esta masa se siga moviendo
bueno podemos pensar que hay una idea
similar sobre qué tan difícil va a ser
detener algo que está rotando y ustedes
se pueden imaginar que esta idea ya ha
sido definida y ha sido definida como el
momento angular esto de aquí es momento
momento lineal para ser más específicos
y de este lado tenemos momento angular
momento angular y de hecho ambas
cantidades tanto el momento lineal como
el momento angular son cantidades
vectoriales de hecho aquí solo escribí
la magnitud de la velocidad pero
realmente es un vector
voy a hacer un poquito de espacio aquí
para que me quepa que el momento está
rom es un vector le pongo su fecha y
está encima la masa es escalar
multiplicada por la velocidad
este es un vector y lo mismo es cierto
para el momento angular aunque vamos a
enfocarnos en la magnitud del momento
angular obviamente este momento angular
puede tener una dirección y podemos
rotarlo de dos maneras diferentes pero
se empieza a complicar un poco más esto
cuando tratamos de encontrar los
productos de los vectores aunque en un
futuro veremos que hay diferentes formas
de obtener el producto de dos vectores
pero para tener la intuición de lo que
es el momento angular vamos a enfocarnos
solamente en la magnitud así que el
momento angular y aquí la letra que
vamos a usar es la l estuve investigando
para tratar de descubrir por qué usaron
esta letra y realmente no encontré
alguna razón y de hecho si ustedes
conocen cuál es la razón de haber
elegido esta letra póngalo en los
comentarios abajo ya que a mí me
gustaría saber por qué el momento
angular se asocia con esta ley
y de hecho a uno de los argumentos que
escuché era que eligieron esta letra
porque todas las demás que estaban
relacionadas ya las habían usado en
otros conceptos bueno de cualquier
manera el momento angular está definido
de una forma bastante similar así como
el torque es algo que puede cambiar la
forma en que rota algo y la fuerza es
algo que puede cambiar cómo se está
trasladando algo y el torque es fuerza
por distancia a partir del centro de
rotación todo lo que se encuentra en el
mundo de la rotación se define de manera
similar podemos encontrar un análogo en
el mundo de la traslación y esto lo
multiplicamos por la distancia a partir
del centro de rotación por lo que el
momento angular se define como la masa
por la velocidad multiplicado por la
distancia al centro de la rotación y
llamémosle a esta distancia de aquí r
r de radio porque si ustedes se imaginan
que eso se están moviendo de forma
circular r va a ser el radio de dicho
círculo y de hecho vamos a hacer un poco
más cuidadosos aquí esta es la magnitud
de la velocidad que es perpendicular al
radio algunas veces se le llama
velocidad tangencial este símbolo de
aquí es la magnitud de la velocidad
tangencial la cual es perpendicular al
radio que va a ser esta magnitud de aquí
y esto es lo que definimos como momento
angular y aquí les diré que en la
ausencia de una fuerza neta el momento
será constante y sabemos aunque aún no
se los he comprobado matemáticamente que
en la ausencia de torque si el torque es
igual a cero
es decir si no está ocurriendo algún
torque neto entonces no tendremos cambio
alguno en el momento angular y esto lo
veremos matemáticamente en el siguiente
vídeo veremos al final a partir de esto
algo muy interesante que muy
probablemente ustedes hayan observado en
las olimpiadas de invierno o en algún
otro lugar esta es la idea de que con el
simple hecho de cambiar el tamaño del
radio podemos cambiar la velocidad
tangencial en vídeos pasados vimos que
la velocidad tangencial es muy cercana a
la velocidad angular vamos a explorar
esto con más detalle podemos ver
directamente en la fórmula que si él es
constante si r disminuyera de hecho
vamos a escribirlo acá l es igual a la
masa multiplicada por la velocidad
tangencial o la velocidad que es
perpendicular al radio multiplicado por
el radio que sucederá si suponemos que
esto es constante suponiendo que no hay
torque si estamos en este mundo esto de
aquí va a ser constante
constante y que va a suceder si
reducimos r de alguna manera no sé a lo
mejor este cable comienza a enrollarse
en el clavo y con cada vuelta se va
haciendo más corto si r disminuye y la
masa va a ser constante así que esa no
puede cambiar si él es constante la masa
no se puede cambiar r está disminuyendo
lo único que puede cambiar y que de
hecho aumenta es la velocidad tangencial
aquella que es perpendicular al radio la
velocidad perpendicular al radio va a
aumentar y si pensamos esto en términos
de la velocidad angular nosotros sabemos
que la velocidad angular que se mide en
radial es por segundo y cuyo símbolo es
omega omega se define y eso lo hemos
visto con más detalle en vídeos
anteriores como
la velocidad tangencial dividida entre
el radio o si despejamos la velocidad
tangencial
tendremos que ver es igual a omega x r
si nosotros sustituimos está definición
en la fórmula del momento angular vamos
a tener que este momento angular va a
ser igual a la masa multiplicado por
esto por r y aquí estoy sustituyendo la
velocidad masa por omega por r por r
entonces vamos a tener el real cuadrado
y nuevamente hacemos el mismo ejercicio
si nuestro radio disminuye que le va a
pasar a nuestra velocidad angular
recordemos que esto podemos medirlo como
ángulos por segundo o radiales por
segundo y si esto es constante recuerden
que estamos suponiendo que no hay un
torque neto aquí si ponemos que esto no
cambie pero el radio es el que está
cambiando que le va a pasar a omega pues
omega va a aumentar de la misma manera
si nuestro radio aumenta si el radio
aumenta que le va
omega 3 omega va a disminuir si
reducimos el radio comenzaremos a dar
vueltas más rápidamente si aumentamos
ese radio daremos vueltas más lentamente
y yo creo que muy probablemente ustedes
ya han visto esto en las olimpiadas
cuando se ve el patinaje sobre hielo
cuando comienzan a girar tienen los
brazos extendidos y cuando tienen los
brazos extendidos podemos decir que su
radio es más grande aunque claro una
patinadora es un sistema mucho más
complejo que un punto de masa pueden
imaginarse a una patinadora que es un
conjunto de puntos de masa cada uno con
diferentes radios y habría que sumar
todos sus momentos angulares pero la
esencia de lo que sucede aquí es que
cuando la patinadora tiene los brazos
extendidos el radio promedio de todos
sus puntos de masa que la conforman el
radio promedio va a ser mayor y cuando
ella contrae los brazos pega los brazos
a su cuerpo ese radio disminuye y
comienza a aumentar su velocidad angular
es decir comienza a dar vueltas más
rápidamente y eso sucede sin aplicar
ningún torque con solo contraer sus
brazos con pegarlos a su cuerpo
comenzarán a dar vueltas más rápidamente
y al extender sus brazos sin aplicar
ningún torque comenzarán a dar vueltas
más lentamente